we are keeping ourselves from a destiny
that we signed up for whatever you need
will begin to show up the problem with
most of us is that as it begins to show
up we then Institute the thing that
keeps us from formalizing and
manifesting and creating the destiny
that we signed up for it's why I say to
you with absolute certainty when you
have the passion just the presence of
the passion and nothing nothing more
that's all you need just the presence of
it is a guarantee for you that you have
the capacity to manifested attracted and
created in whatever form you would like
it to show up just because you have the
passion and the Dow doesn't teach you to
think big thinks you to it teaches you
to think small thinking big is a mistake
according to the D because when you
think big you can't get big things done
we can only do things in this moment so
it teaches us to be be in this moment it
says you can get anywhere from here it's
really simple you go through what you
have to go through even the torturous
things that you have to go through in
order to be able to give because the
most important thing that you can learn
according to Lau is that when you are at
one with what is called the hidden
virtue the hidden virtue which is the
hidden godliness kindness goodness love
that is in you and what you came from
when you are in harmony with that all of
your life is about giving when you're
not in harmony with the hidden virtue
all of your life is about getting so you
make the shift from getting what's in it
for me how much am I going to make how
well am I going to do what does my ego
say to how may I serve what may I give
how can I do it Wayne Dyer was an icon
in self-development and spiritual growth
he wrote over 40 books with an
astonishing 21 New York Times
bestsellers his childhood was spent in
orphanages and Foster homes but he'd go
on to inspire millions and become known
as the father of motivation in this
exclusive speech from the celebrate your
life stage Wayne Dyer shares with us the
keys to manifesting your dreams staying
in the present moment and living in
harmony with the TOA special thanks to
Liz Don for partnering with us to
release this exclusive content on our
YouTube channel enjoy so I want to share
with you what has been uh happening in
my life in the last year it's been a
magical year it's been a transformative
year and I got involved in doing
something that um not only produced a
book which I completed U two days ago
but more than it being another book that
I've written it was something that um
allowed me to see the incredible power
of of passion and enthusiasm and when
you get it in your hearts and my
objective in the short time that I have
here with you today is to to convey that
to you what you need what you're
supposed to do how it will work out what
financing is required what uh people
you'll need what circumstances you will
need to align with uh the stars or
whatever all will be taken care of if
you stay with your passion and I'd like
to suggest to you that whatever your
passion is and even if you don't know
what it is whatever the feeling you have
inside of you that says to you this is
what you're here for you have to do this
as absurd as it may sound as ridiculous
as it may appear to everyone in your
environment including your husband and
your children and your wife and your
ex-wife and your grandchildren and your
neighbors and the people you work with
and the people you encounter everywhere
you go it may sound like the most absurd
thing for someone of your age at this
time given these circumstances of your
life to to be contemplating even
contemplating something so crazy
whatever it might be and yet if you can
hold on to the passion just hold on to
that hold on to the passion what you're
doing when you're holding on to the
passion is you're holding on to God
because um the word enthusiasm and
passion are the same and Theos from the
Greek is God yasm means within
enthusiasm is the God within you the god
within you and this voice if you read uh
the 10 secrets for success and inner
peace I put out for my children several
years ago I wrote it for my teenagers
because I put down in there the 10 most
significant and important ideas that I
thought they should know long after I
was
gone one of those ideas was the second
one it's called Uh don't die with your
music still in you that you came here
with music to play so not dying with
your music Still In is a very important
uh idea it's one of 10 that I carried
with me for a long time and wrote it so
that they would have it and be able to
read that and know what I was speaking
about but beyond that is something that
I have come to know and that is when you
have that passion and you hang on to it
and you don't let any obstacle come in
your way you're hanging on to God and
another synonym for God is love right
out of the New Testament God is love
and he that dwelleth in love dwelleth in
me and I in him so now we're looking at
um enthusiasm being something or passion
being something that uh relates to your
staying connected to a field of energy
that is dominated by something called
love and that is God
itself and we all have this wonderful
Choice as we come into this world and
the choice is whether we're going to
stay aligned with that or not the
writing that I have been doing is from
something called the Dao D Ching now the
Dao the Ching Tao it's pronounced d but
it's ta
ta T Ching the great way was um written
was dictated I should say 2,500 years
ago it's the longest surviving spiritual
text on our planet and the most uh sales
of any other thing other than the Bible
the da
ching and very few of us know very much
about it but you
will it's interesting because it was uh
written and created at the very same
time as the Bhagavad Gita 2500 years ago
Buddha Lau were contemporaries as was
confucious and zoroaster Socrates all of
these beings were walking on the planet
at the same time it was a it was a vort
Vortex an intellectual spiritual Vortex
not long after people were just crawling
out of caves 2500 years ago remember
when we think of the Middle Ages that
was 12 or 1300 years later this was 500
years 500 years five centuries before
the birth of Christ this man who lived
at um at God Consciousness at God
realization was dictating to um a guard
they say as he was leaving his village
in ancient China and he gave these
verses and there are 81 of them 81
Infinite Source once 81 bhavat Gita
being written at the same time has 18
verses in it one Infinite Source and
there are 18 holes on a golf course I
mean how do
you put that all together there's got to
be a connection there there's got to be
so these 81 vers is um I got this idea
and I I never know where the next thing
is going to come from and it's it's why
I say to you with absolute certainty
when you have the passion just the
presence of the passion and nothing more
that's all you need just the presence of
it is a guarantee for
you that you have the capacity to
manifested attracted and create it in
whatever form you would like it to show
up just because you have the passion
because it's a knowing within you and
when you stay with it and align yourself
with it the book you have to write the
um music you have to uh create the
artwork that you have to do the child
that you absolutely must adopt the um
business that you have to open up
someplace out there that uh no one else
understands or grasps the thing that
won't go away the thing that won't go
away when you keep it there when you
stay aligned with it and you keep that
alignment in harmony with with god with
Spirit whatever you need will begin to
show up the problem with most of us is
that as it begins to show up we then
Institute the thing that keeps us from
formalizing and manifesting and creating
the destiny that we signed up for things
like doubts Shakespeare said our doubts
are our traitors
these are traitors these are things that
we live with and we hang on to and we
spout and we talk about and we don't
realize that in just the most innocuous
and innocent of ways we are keeping
ourselves from a destiny that we signed
up for long before we ever entered into
this world of form so I was um in
England about a year and a half ago I
was lecturing over there and friend of
mine in the United States one of my best
friends told me about a book that he
thought I should read he said it's so
well written and it's so impactful I
think you should uh you should read it
and then I kept seeing you know this is
what happens we call these car Yun coin
the term synchronicity or Synchro
Destiny as deot calls it and it's um
this idea that there's sort of a
collaboration with fate that begins to
take place when we stay connected to and
attached to our passion not to how it'll
happen not to if it'll happen not to
when it will happen but just to it we
just stay there and then we get into
that state of bewilderment and awe and
as we stay in that state of bewilderment
in awe we start seeing a change take
place I call this book um change your
thoughts change your life living the
wisdom of the doubted ching and it's 81
essays that I channeled from lau and you
know I say that and I think oh but you
know what I'm 66 it's going to get a
little weird now in these
last and when it does I'm going to point
it out so that you don't think I don't
know that it's a little weird that I'm
channeling a 2500 year old China but I
want to tell you how this happened and
then end with something that's I I can't
even wait to give you what's going to
happen in the last hour I can hardly
wait to get to that one so
good but I got to go through this first
is this is even
better so the book was called a million
little pieces many of you saw it know
about it it became a huge bestseller
this was before anybody had spoken
anything about it James fry and then
this huge controversy came up about a
memoir and whether all the facts were
straight and he was a drug addict he was
addicted to heroin he was addicted to
crack cocaine he was drinking two or
three bottles of vka a day he was 27
years old he was days away from Death he
was dumped off at uh up in Minnesota
place called Hazelton and went into
rehab and he wrote his account looking
back on it from 18 years of sobriety
looking back on it and some of the facts
were shifted and changed and as one of
my children said he was a drug addict
and he exaggerated du
duh is that a big surprise and the whole
controversy that emerged on this uh
subject and so um overshadowed the
importance of this book and this man and
what it did for so many people whose
lives were just ripped out from under
them with drugs prescription drugs uh
illegal drugs legal drugs whatever it's
a huge huge problem we face in our
society today and it isn't just illegal
drugs it's like you're getting bombarded
every day on television on the radio and
Time Magazine full page ads USA Today
whatever with more and more and more
inclinations to go to your physician and
tell them which drugs that you want and
they are invested in the drug companies
and the drug companies are making
billions of dollars and charging $10 for
a pill that cost a penny and then the
chances of getting a uh an erection that
lasts 4 hours
is that's very real in there you know
there's got to be a lot of sexual
dysfunction in this country because
there's a commercial every 2 minutes
isn't it I don't know I have an erection
that lasts 4 hours going to my doctor is
the last place I'm heading I'm telling
you that right
now I have several stops I want to make
before I show up I
talk so I uh I read this book and I was
fascinated by it being a camel myself a
camel is an animal who starts out every
day on his knees he goes to bed every
night on his
knees and U he goes 24 hours without a
drink I've been a camel for 19 years now
I go to bed and wake up up an addiction
is something I'm very very very familiar
with very much of an addictive
personality I started running in 1976 I
ran 8 Miles when I finally got to 8
Miles and then it was 1998 it was 22
years later and I was still running 8
Miles every single day for 22 years some
call it
obsessive some call it addictive and uh
and I've been down that road with things
like nicotine and things like alcohol
and drugs and uh and caffeine and uh
sugars and things like that have all
been things in my own life that I showed
up to and one of the things I've come to
know is that everything that you have to
deal with every problem that you face
every struggle you have to overcome
whatever it might be as the da teaches
it has uh uh Good Fortune is hidden in
all
Misfortune you have to know that and
that the way that the Dow works is that
nothing sustains itself the same so that
every storm that shows up in your life
every storm that shows up in the world
has calmness hidden within it and has a
drought hidden within it as well and
it's the way of things the only constant
is the da but the problem with the da is
as it says in the first chapter is that
the da that can be named is not the da
so you can't talk about it you have to
just experience it you have to go within
and come to know that there is a
constant there is an energy there is a
force for which all things originate all
things originate including you and
particles themselves do not create more
particles so you didn't come from a
particle you came from an energy field
that allowed a particle to formulate in
a split second called creation that's
the way of Dao and returning to Dao
verse 40 of The Da to Ching says that uh
returning is the way of Da returning is
the way of Da returning and yielding
your job is to return to the place from
which you originated now some including
the poets suggest that um the only way
to do that is through death TS Elliot
the great uh it's actually born in St
Louis I don't know if most of you knew
that in
1888 died in 1965 at the age of 77 said
we shall all we shall cease from
exploration and at the end of our
exploring will be to return to the place
from which we started and know it for
the first time we shall not cease from
exploration and at the end of all of our
exploring shall be to return to the
place from which we started and know it
for the first time he's suggesting in
that poetic offering for which he won
the Nobel Prize for literature in 1948
he's suggesting in there that um the
only way you'll ever know it is to die
you'll return to the place from which
you came and at your death you will know
where you came from in that originating
place and know it for the first time now
I don't like to argue with TS Elliot or
Lau but I would suggest that um we can
return and enter into a state of God
realization and harmonize ourselves with
Dow now and activate it and create it
and in the process gain all that the
originating Force allowed or intended us
to become which is what we signed up for
before we came it's possible now and
I'll be talking a little bit later about
how to access it and what happens when
you do for now when you read or if you
do read a million little pieces you
discover that this young man in his 20s
when he went into this rehab facility to
overcome something that um when people
reach that level of addiction very few
ever survive it people who do crystal
meth they say they have uh six out of
100 100 recover from it 94 end up dying
and that's an epidemic where I live on
Maui it's called Ice Six out of 100 is
the success rate 94 are going to
continue taking it they're going to get
something called Meth
mouth which means your teeth turn to the
consistency of a peach and fall out and
your body deteriorates and that stuff is
out there and that's just
one so he was doing that as well but
something happened to him in there and
he had a much bigger assignment if you
will or sign
up because while he was in this uh rehab
facility he refused to do the things
that the program prescribed for him he
wouldn't do the AA thing he didn't do
the 12 Steps he thought that that he
didn't want to substitute one kind of
addiction for another he found himself
putting it all down being very resistant
to um any kind of authority being very
much like the kind of behavior that
probably got him going in that whole
world of addiction in the first place
but what he did do every
day is read the da Ching the 81 verses
which you can read in about 81 minutes
only takes a minute to read a verse of
the da ching and then you can study any
one of them for a lifetime as you'll
hear a little bit later on so um as I
would read through this thing and see
him resisting the first step and the
second step and not going to meetings
and not doing any of the thing and being
very just resistant to any kind of
authority but he kept saying the da the
da and all this time while I was reading
it I see I knew about the da I I I knew
about La 2 I sort of had a vision of
what he looked like and um based on
paintings and renderings that had
survived over centuries but I had never
really studied it I taught a course in
philosophy at a university back in the
70s and I would do one lecture on dosm
just sort of skim through it and get on
to the real stuff you know because the
doist don't believe in a god that is a
white dead male in heaven floating
around as a cosmic
Bellboy who is going to offer you if you
pray hard enough to something outside of
you as Carl Yung who was a Dost said
that uh the shest way to lose your soul
is to believe in a God that exists
outside of yourself the shest way to
lose your soul he also said that the
purpose of organized religion is to
prevent as many people as possible from
having a direct experience of God a
direct experience a knowing god so the
doubt doesn't teach about knowing about
God the da teaches about knowing god and
the da Sees God in nature and in
yourself and in all things inescapably
connected to All Things the source of
all creation it does nothing but it
leaves nothing undone doing nothing and
leaving nothing undone is a wonderful
Paradox try it sometime I I've been
doing that even in my swim in the
morning on the ocean in the Pacific I've
been practicing swimming with by doing
nothing but just letting my body do what
it knows how to do just letting it move
through the water without my having any
effort and just watching good example of
it right now is there's what 1500 2,000
people in this room there's not one
person in here who's beating his heart
or her heart and yet every heart is
being beaten so the Dow teaches all of
us that you're doing nothing you're just
being done you're in the process of
being done by a force that is handling
everything for you and handled it from
the very beginning very interesting
because the first nine months of your
life from the moment of conception until
the moment of birth in those first nine
months you totally stayed out of the
picture and so did everybody else it's
just you totally surrendered you just
let go as they say in the recovery
movement you let go and what you let God
you just let God so you didn't have a
nose when they took a little picture in
there but you didn't go through you know
praying oh God please deliver me a nose
and don't put a bump on it and don't
make it look to this or to that and you
handled everything got handled in
exactly Divine timing Divine Perfection
and you just let go and so did your
mother you just let go and allowed and
allowed and it all happened and then you
were born and you said good work God
I'll take over from from here and so did
your parents and all of your neighbors
and your culture will take over nice
work and the moment that you did that
you made your biggest
mistake and the da myself here today
teaching about how to get back to that
place of doing nothing but leaving
nothing undone allowing rather than
resisting not fighting so
synchronicities begin to happen when the
passion is there and I had finished this
book on inspiration and this brand new
new book about balance called being in
Balance which has just come out I'm so
proud of about aligning ourselves and uh
and staying connected to our source and
keeping a balance between our habits and
what we desire and as always it's like
when you have the passion and when and
when you know you're being used you know
when you start realizing that you're
being done like your body's being done
you know that I mean this is a city that
has the largest number of plastic
surgeons per capital than any City in
the world yeah right here Scottdale
Arizona there's one right across the
street when I was running this morning
about 400 doctors in there but you can
plasticize everything in your body it
doesn't make any any difference it's
still being done and it's going to leave
in Divine timing exactly when it was
supposed to there's absolutely nothing
for you to be concerned about in the
moment of your conception in the moment
of your movement from Spirit to to form
your birth was handled your height was
handled the color of your eyes was
handled everything that you needed your
body structure was all handled for you
in the microscopic dot of a on a pin you
can put a billion of these that's how
tiny it was and everything you needed
for this journey was all handled in
there your death must have been in there
if your birth was in there isn't it I
mean it's it's just all it's just you're
just being done and if you could be done
by staying in rapport with the source
from which you originated and Know It
For the First Time really know it the
ability to be able to attract manifest
provide what it is that you are here for
would become something which would um
keep you bewildered it would keep you in
a state of awe you would see it forming
now reading a million little pieces and
I was in England and I picked it up and
I set it down and then I said no I don't
want to carry it through because you
know it was heavy and I it was before it
was in paperback and I wasn't sure if I
got and I get back and uh somebody had
sent me a copy and then uh you know I
was sort of thumbing through it and I
gave it to uh somebody to read and my
children started reading it and I sent
it to one of my daughters who struggles
with addictions even to this day
dramatically in fact she's right now
working working working on uh on her
total sobriety she's uh I've just talked
to her half an hour ago and uh you can't
imagine how how how much peace there is
in knowing that someone is safe in a
place being helped and wanting to do it
checking herself in so and then the
author appears on a uh television show
that I happen to be flipping through and
then you know it's like it just keeps
coming at you as if to say you know I
got something for you to do and you
already signed up to do it a millennia
ago or a 2,000 Millennia ago you know
how do I get your attention you know you
got to do it because unless you just
keep saying no I can't do do that or it
won't work or I don't have the ability
or I don't have the luck or these kinds
of things have never worked out for me
before or whatever it might be those
things that we call resistance begin to
become our mode of dealing with it and
before you know it resistance is what we
start believing in and then we start
believing in our limitations and we
start arguing for them and uh defending
all the reasons why it can't happen when
all you have to do is be in love all you
have to do is be in love all you have to
do is stay in love stay in that place of
ecstasy and then just watch just watch
and you'll see it showing up in so many
ways I was still not knowing what this
was about I don't have a drinking
problem I bet it's been 19 years all
right that's recover okay that's not
still working on it that's not an issue
it's not even a possibility for me but
there it was and the only thing that
kept this man who was destined to die in
a few short months from going back to it
was the da Ching Steven Mitchell's
version of The Da Ching who's an
American so I was thinking about it and
every time I talked to my friend he
would tell me about this and you got to
read this and I said read I got so many
other things I'm working on on it said
you got to read this why are you bugging
me telling me what I got to read you
know do you know what I'm talking about
this this is just my experience but you
you get these these things are happening
to you now even being here even
something I might have said or something
whatever it might be already somebody's
here who didn't even know they were
going to be here this morning and still
don't even know what who I
am and you may be wondering what am I
doing here and when's it going to get to
the point and what's the you know what
and the point is you're here and there's
no accidents in this uh Universe there's
an organizing intelligence that's
supporting everything the whole thing is
all held together that same Force that's
beating every heart in this room is
holding the planet in alignment
with all the rest of them and uh and
opening the flowers and closing them and
providing us with the trees and the food
and it's like the whole thing is all
being done and so I accepted a speaking
engagement out in Wyoming which I didn't
want to take last summer September I
guess a year ago last September to speak
for some Grand tetan conference or
something out there and uh and I was
speak I was in England in fact and and
uh when I left England I told the woman
that kept calling me and calling me a
lot like these two here like Liz and
mother giving me wonderful people and I
mean
that I said look I'm flying in from
England and then I've got to go to
Wyoming and I said there's no flights
for that and I was you know using all
the thing I said you it's just not
possible I I simply just can't go there
she said there's no problem with that
I'll send we'll send a plane her
sister's married to Oscar deara okay who
likes the sister as much as his wife and
uh
so we'll send Oscar dentus plane to you
and we'll pick you up and I said no no
you don't understand my daughter has got
to you know I don't do it unless she
goes with me and she's going and she he
said that's no problem she can get on
the plane too and then we'll fly her
back to where they there we were flying
across the country on this private plane
landing in the Jackson Hole and uh going
off to this Grand Teton thing and I get
the talk and uh that uh that night I met
uh a woman who was also speaking the
next morning and doing a workshop at the
same conference her name is Byron Katie
I'm sure many of you have heard of her
she's wonderful wonderful being one of
my all-time favorite human beings on the
planet and I was going through some
particular difficulty at that time
family and stuff and and when I finished
my talk about 11:00 she stayed up with
me till almost 3:00 in the morning and
worked with me doing something called
the work was her whole idea is that we
have all of these thoughts we have so
many thoughts that we have every single
day the only problem is that uh most of
them are not
true in fact hardly any of them are and
yet we act as if they are and we live by
these truths that he must love me and
you must do this and things must be that
way and and none of them are true the
opposite is just as likely to be true of
almost every thought that you have as
the thought that you have and she shows
you how to do that in something called
the work now we've uh put together a
program together I spoke with her out in
pasaden for an all day workshop they're
putting it out and we're like very very
close friends so I'm talking to her and
and she said my husband is here with me
and I said oh what's his name oh his
name is Steven Mitchell I said oh really
yeah she's married to the guy who
translated the daed
Ching so I said enough you know in
Hawaii they have this thing it's called
enough already enough already that's how
they talk right so I said so I I began
reading through it and uh and then um I
saw the whole controversy and I was I I
just felt that
he didn't get a fair Shake there you
know I I really U I think when you have
a choice to be right or to be kind like
picking kind is really important and uh
and he made a big mistake by not having
a disclaimer at the beginning that some
of the facts had been changed but the
man had helped so many people and you
know what after I read it I picked up
the phone because this publisher had
dropped him and I said look I talked to
Louise Louise hey who's my publisher and
I said you know they're going to drop
this guy from publishing and she said
whatever he wants to publish we'll
publish and we'll pay them whatever he
was being paid that's Louise so I called
I found I got his number from Steven he
had also forgotten to give credit to
Steven for the da of Ching quotes
throughout the million little pieces but
he didn't know he was you know he didn't
know and as soon as he found out he
corrected it which he was willing to do
with everything else as well he's such a
decent really good beautiful human being
and I called him and I told him about my
daughter who was in rehab and was
struggling with addictions and all that
and he said what's her name and I said
look if you just talk to her for 5
minutes just for 5 minutes cuz she read
your book it would mean so much to me so
much and he said I'll talk to her for 5
hours or 5 days or I'll move in with her
for 5 weeks if that's what it takes I'll
do whatever it takes to help her and he
did and called her and encouraged her to
stop the bull as he said stop all of the
excuses and get on get on with your
sobriety and uh it made a huge huge
impact in her life so you can imagine
I'm a bit of a
fan so this thing this thing from this
uh called the da Ching which he told me
he said I read it every day I read it
every day and each day when I read it it
was the only thing that got me through
it because I fought all the rest of it
and I thought if somebody can be in that
state where they're so close to death
and something written 2500 years Years
Ago by a little who just gave
this to a guard and dictated it and said
these are the essential truths of life
and live them I said I've got to get
into this thing I've got to get in and I
talked to my publisher I talked to
Louise I said I'm going to write I'm
going to take each of the 81 verses of
The Da and I'm going to write for a year
and I started January the 1st of this
year and I'm going to start and write an
essay every 3 or 4 days but before I do
what I want to do is create a place and
this is something I really want you to
think about I want you to create a
sacred place in your home in your
bedroom wherever it might be in your
office in your garage it doesn't make
any difference and you don't need to
have you can live in a one-bedroom
apartment and do this and in this sacred
place I'd like you to um put your energy
into it I have a place like this on Maui
and it's a place that is I Revere it's
just a little dining room
but in it it has everything that has
sacred value to me in it books that
people have sent me photographs crystals
that people have offered to me in the
way of there's a I I had four different
drawings of lau and I had them framed 8
by1 and I have them right there as I
look at them along with one of Sababa my
teacher who comes and visits me in my
soul and my dream and my heart and uh
has the gift of Fish and Loaves on this
planet today we'll be celebrating his
80th birthday in two
weeks uh and um is this person who has
this gift to Fish and Loaves has
manifested for me a ziplock bag a quart
bag you know like the kind you take on
the airlines filled with vuti my answer
to the Airlines and not taking shampoo
on a plane is right here I want you to
know so in this Sacred Space where where
I light a candle every morning in fact I
I light three candles one to Lau one to
Ralph Waldo Emerson who 8 by10
photograph is in front of me and one to
sa Baba and they are there and it may
sound silly but what happens as I walked
by this sacred spot in my home where I
do this writing with all of these things
that are in it as I walk by I get up at
3:00 in the morning as you
know if you watch the PBS show between
3:00 and 4: every morning and in that
quiet time when you're closest to God as
again roomie said the breeze at dawn has
secrets to tell you do not go back to
sleep do not go back to sleep you're all
awakened between 3 and 4 virtually every
one of you that wakeup call is not an
accident it's a universal Human
Experience it's the quietest time it's
the time when there's the least
distractions God's one and only voice is
silence silence that place place where
you can be connected and as you get up
and fill your body with the supplements
that you take with the antioxidant
drinks that you take with whatever it is
the nanogreens that I drink and all of
the things that I fill myself with in
the morning with this healthy wonderful
feeling of good things going through my
body not coffee not cigarettes not not
poisons but you know really life
affirming food
and as you walk by this place with the
candles burning and so on it will draw
you into it it will draw you there you
feel as if you have to enter this space
whatever it might be your Sacred Space
and when you sit down in that space in
the middle of the night and allow
yourself to know that what you are here
for is now going to be made manifest for
you you begin to allow it to come
through you now come on everything is
channeled God writes all the books and
builds all the bridges I mean who do you
think is delivering this talk this is
just Rena dire this isn't me this is
like these words that are coming here
from where where are they coming from
who owns these words that come here and
go into this little thing that I'm
holding in my hand and titilate the
stapes in your in your ear so that you
can hear these vibrations we don't own
any of this stuff this isn't mine I
don't get any of this is I get the
royalties you know but it's not it's
like you begin to realize that you can
be used as an instrument as a vessel for
anything and when you get your ego out
of it and that's what Lau teaches more
than anything else about leadership
particularly about leadership
particularly and this is that the great
leaders emulate the ocean and what is
the ocean but the greatest source of
power on the planet and why is the ocean
the greatest source of of of power on
the planet because it stays low all of
the rivers and all of the streams are
all in work at Flowing toward the ocean
it all flows back and it flows back
because the ocean doesn't Lord itself
over anyone it practices radical
humility it stays low it interferes not
at all it just allows it allows
everything non-interfering is probably
the base is the basis of the Dow and we
need to have an awareness of this in our
leaders the um eventually leadership
political leaders Community leaders
Business Leaders when we have enough of
us and I'm doing a whole I'm doing a a
weekend seminar on living the da
inviting people from all over the planet
to come to Maui next October and um to
be there for a uh a way of living the da
and putting it into practice everywhere
in our lives so that I think it's the
57th verse of the da says that uh any
country which is has its most of its
energy invested in weapons is not of The
Da and any country that has most of its
energy invested in building homes and
growing food for the masses
and not interfering with them is
connected to the DA is living the da
from a distance from a great distance if
you were to look at this planet now I've
been writing from a distance for the
last year yesterday morning was the
first morning this year that I got up
and I didn't have to I I wasn't required
by my inner passion to study the next
verse of the da and then walk it for a
day and then think about it and meditate
it on on a day what a job an incredible
job I can't even imagine what they pay
me for it just that's all I have to do
is get up read the da ask and then
meditate on it swim on it do yoga on it
all of the things that I do every day
and then one day before I write it look
at these pictures of Lau one sitting on
an oxen and ask him you wrote it 2500
years ago the language is a little
different than our language today how do
people apply this today in the 21st
century how would what would you say and
then I just put my arm on the table and
allow it to flow through my heart and
onto the page with my little purple pen
and my white pad of paper and it just
there's writer's block is impossible
when you're living your passion when
you're living your passion you're living
with God when you're living with God
you're living love you are not and what
does the course and Miracle say there's
only two emotions what are they love and
fear and all that is love what cannot be
fear and all that is fear cannot be love
so fear and God are opposites there's no
fear there's only love and when you're
in love when you're in love when you're
in
love and
allowing there's no blockages there's no
obstacles all you have to do is align
yourself in such a way that you allow it
to happen one of the great books that
has just come out just came out last
week I spoke up in San Francisco and I
had 10 cases of these shipped up there
in San Francisco this is to me the the
the profound the the profound teaching
on the planet today I learned so much
from this it's called The Law of
Attraction Esther and Jerry Hicks just
came out and it's all of the basics of
the teachings of Abraham so from a
distance it's a beautiful book it's
really worth reading it's one you want
to study the teachings I I'll go a
little bit into it a little bit more
later on but the idea of from a distance
is that
here's 2500 years have passed 2500 years
but there's no time so it's like Lau is
here and I could easily be getting the
same information that was given to him
to give only in the language of the 21st
century why not why would there be
anything to stop that when you think
like that and the Dow doesn't teach you
to think big think you it teaches you to
think small thinking big is a mistake
according to the D because when you
think big you can't get big things done
we can only do things in this moment so
it teaches us to be in this moment it
says you can get anywhere from here you
can get anywhere from here the key is
you have to be here like you have to
totally be here so that anything big
that you want to do like 19 years ago
when I decided to give up alcohol or
when it was decided for me cuz I was
just being done I did it I know what
addiction is about then I can teach
about it I lived in an orphanage AG for
10 years so that I could understand
self-reliance then I could teach it it's
really simple hi there my name is Liz
Dawn and I am the co-creator of
celebrate your life events and I hope
you're loving this amazing workshop with
the late and great Dr Wayne Dyer this
was recorded live at one of our
celebrate your life conferences and I'm
so excited that we could share this very
special workshop with all of the Evan
carmichel fans and to learn more about
us just click the link below and visit
celebrate yourlife.com you go through
what you have to go through even the
torturous things that you have to go
through in order to be able to give
because the most important thing that
you can learn according to La too is
that when you are at one with what is
called the hidden virtue the hidden
virtue which is the hidden godliness
kindness goodness love that is in you
and what you came from when you are in
harmony with that all of your life life
is about giving when you're not in
harmony with the hidden virtue all of
your life is about getting so you make
the shift from getting what's in it for
me how much am I going to make how well
am I going to do what does my ego say to
how may I serve what may I give how can
I do it and if I'd have thought 19 years
ago that I was going to not be able to
have another beer for 19 years it's too
big it's too big you can't even do that
you can't not drink for 19 years you can
only not drink now and that's easy so
you don't even if you've got a great big
project in M you bring yourself down
bring yourself down to what can we do
here now today and that's what you do
what you can be here now which is what
all of nature knows to do every raccoon
knows this every bat knows this so from
a distance I've been talking to this man
and wondering at the beginning who am I
do you know how many translations there
are of the da that I came across when I
Googled it when I didn't Google it my
daughter Googled it I don't know how to
Google anything I don't even have a
computer I've never done an email I
don't do emails there's about 7,000
translations that just are translated
into English of The Da Ching of the 81
verses so and and they they're similar
and some say this and some use that word
and this word and I picked the dozen of
the ones that seem to be the most
relevant and I read each my I would read
12 translations of the first verse of
the da Chen and then I would meditate on
it and then I would do yoga on it and I
would allow myself to just let it come
into me and sometimes when I would read
one I just thought I don't know how to
do this I don't know how to I just and
then I would let go of that and just
amazingly and especially especially when
I would enter that Sacred Space
especially it would just flow it's just
I can only say it with all the passion
that I feel it right now in this moment
it works if you're willing to let go if
you're willing to go back to what your
life was like in the first nine months
and surrender and not worry and get out
of the way and then be in a state of
disg gratitude if the only prayer you
say every day every day the only prayer
you say is thank you that's enough
you're on your way it's staying in that
state of gratitude and knowing and never
fighting it and whatever comes even if
it doesn't make any sense to you
whatsoever you embrace it you embrace it
because that passion that you feel is
God speaking to you saying don't die
with your music Still In you don't get
to that place everything looks different
from a distance when you get back
imagine stepping back and looking at
this entire planet from a distance and I
kept thinking about that and every time
I would look at this picture of lau and
I would ask and then the day before the
writing would be so sweet so perfect and
I'd call my editor and I'd read it and
I'd say I'm L Cho I what you know what's
going on here I'm going to be speaking
Chinese next I don't uh it was
overwhelmingly powerful to do this and
then I heard a song was written by uh
Julie gold in 1985 and it was sung by uh
B Midler in 1990 at the outbreak of the
Gulf War it touched me to a point where
I got that goose flesh which I'm getting
right now when I heard that song written
by a 30-year-old girl there's so many
beautiful words in that song I mean does
that war make any sense from a distance
I mean when we look back and we look
back at training people to go and kill
other people the Dallas says the people
when you go to war it says that the
people will prevail who have no enemies
even if they have to go to war and that
all victories should be treated as a
funeral as a funeral and an apology
needs to be offered to all of those who
were vanquished saying we just didn't
know a better way but we'll figure one
out no enemies imagine a world in which
there are no enemies from a distance
I've been sitting there writing across
the miles and across the centuries
listening to someone speak to me when I
don't even hear the voice I just let it
flow and it flows out in Perfect Harmony
540 individual Pages handwritten which
will be edited all without one moment of
Doubt without one moment of
consideration for writer block or not
knowing whether it will happen from that
same perspective for every single one of
you in this room there is an awareness
that there is something grander and
greater that awaits you when you get
back to that first nine months of your
life where you surrender and let go and
allow it to come and flow I want to read
something to
you from um Carl Yung who was a doist I
mean he lived and talked and wrote a lot
about the da I was a jungian therapist I
was trained in that discipline many
years ago it's called the stages of
life now there's a morning and an
afternoon of your life which is I'm
going to write next starting January the
1st I'm going to start on this the
morning of our life doesn't have
anything to do with your age some people
never have a morning of their life like
Jesus Lau Buddha
zoraster the great spiritual
teachers they just show up and they
don't have to go through certain kinds
of things that we are trained but I had
a morning of my life and an afternoon
and I'm in an evening the morning of Our
Lives we are taught certain things from
the time that we emerge from the womb
and what we are taught when we emerge
from the womb is um almost everything
the opposite of living D Consciousness
living the hidden virtues
Living God realization in the presence
of a god realized being the laws of the
material world do not apply they just
don't apply healing can take place
instantaneously for anything the right
person can show up right out of nowhere
in the biggest surprise that you've ever
had you can be in more than one place at
the same time you can manifest whatever
it is that you need it'll just be there
and it'll be too weird for you but it'll
just there it is when you get in the
presence or when you yourself enter God
realization that's what I'm calling the
afternoon of our life generally speaking
it takes place somewhere between the
ages of
31 and 44 45 generally very generally
speaking but by and large in the morning
of our life you are learn you learn from
the people around you who are doing
their absolute best to raise you to be
good citizens very likely mothers and
fathers and grandparents and cultures
and the church or organizations and all
the things but most of it is designed to
get you to fit in to be a good person to
uh be a good family member to follow the
rules to get good grades to save for the
future to put your money away to make
sure that uh nobody uh steals your money
from you to have goals to get through
this class and that class to get through
this degree and that degree to graduate
to get it to a certain job to do
whatever it takes on the job in order to
get yourself a promotion all of it being
organized around getting more attracting
as much as you possibly can get it's
about getting it's about getting and
it's about pleasing and it's about
fitting in all of which are ndow
principles all three of those are total
non- Dow princi but that doesn't matter
it's not about the Dow when you're
getting the morning of your life and
then something happens what I call a
Quantum shift takes place and you move
into something called the afternoon of
your life or the evening of your life
and here you your values your desires
what it is that is important to you have
done a complete radical shift it's no
longer that important thing for you to
be a good family member it's no longer
the most important thing for you to
please your parents it's no longer the
most important thing for you to to do to
uh to save for the future or to get good
grades or even to get the the a a good
house the right house you begin to feel
a sense of connectedness to everything
and everyone from a distance you look at
this planet and you think could anything
on here be fighting each other we're all
breathing the same air we're all we all
came from the same place how could there
possibly be enemies when you look at it
from that there's an interconnectedness
that's why I've often said that uh it
makes about as much sense to have a
smoking section in a restaurant as it
does to have a peeing section in a
swimming pool you know it's just uh no
no no no no no no no you don't pee over
there you don't pee over there that's
not a peeing section over here is where
you pee sounds a little crazy to me now
you have to step inside to get a
pressure FR a a pressure FR a yeah I
said that right so we start in the
afternoon of our life there is a shift
and the shift is usually preceded not
always but it can be and I invite you to
open yourself to the possibility that
you can invite and invite in a Quantum
shift and I'll describe it for you in
just a moment and as you as you get to
one of these Quantum shifts in your
life things
that were so important to you in the
morning of your life no longer are
important and I suggest that most people
who would attend a conference such as
this here in this beautiful place on
these beautiful days and sit and listen
to speakers from all over the world come
and talk to you about it that virtually
everyone in this room is moving into or
has moved into something called the
afternoon of your life in which the
general priorities of your life what you
expect out of it what you expect to do
while you're here have
shifted and it no longer satisfies you
it no longer fulfills you to live the
afternoon of your life by the rules that
you learned in the morning of your life
here's what Yung said about all of this
thoroughly
unprepared we take the step into the
afternoon of life we're still we take
this step with the false
presupposition that our truths and our
ideas will serve us as hither two but we
cannot live the afternoon of life
according to the program of life's
morning for what was great in the
morning will be little at evening and
what in the morning was true will at
evening have become a lie it's so
dramatic and so powerful that you get to
the place whether it's in your
relationships or your work or your
family or your community
or your country will you know you're
living a lie and it is increasingly
intolerable for you to continue to do
that and people around you who are still
stuck in the morning of their life are
choosing to stay there and continue to
seek after more more stuff accumulating
more getting more Prestige making more
money getting to another place having a
higher goal people around that becomes
an athema it becomes something that you
feel like an infection in your body just
growing and it isn't that these people
or these events or this place or the
things that you are doing it isn't that
they're bad it isn't that that that
anybody's done anything wrong it's that
you have taken on this shift and
generally when you make this shift I've
got the uh summary just a real brief
summary of how this affects men and
women when a Quantum change takes place
which I haven't described yet but will
will when it takes place and you move
from the number one priority of your
life being to get good grades to fit in
to be a good daughter or a good mother
or to fit in with your family business
or whatever it might whatever it is that
it might be when that shift has
completed itself and you now realize
that there's something greater something
grander something more profound let me
read to you one of the great ladies one
of the great writers ever her name is
Lillian Smith she uh wrote in the 40s
she died in the 70s I believe or 60s
there's an award a literary award given
in her name the Lilian Smith award she
wrote a book that I'm asking Louise to
uh it's out of print to re republish
hopefully I'll have it by next year it's
called The Journey and in the 1940s she
went all through the South and she
looked at integration and the ways that
whites and blacks were whites were
treating blacks in the South and had a
profound change and when you read her
she had a double Mass ectomy also um
which was not ever even talked about
when she was writing in the' 40s and her
writing is so profound but this is what
she says she says to pray it is so
necessary and so hard hard not because
it requires intellect or knowledge or a
big vocabulary or special techniques but
because it requires of us humility and
that comes she said I think from a
profound sense of one's Brokenness and
one's need not the need that comes and
causes us to cry get me out of this
trouble quick please God but the the
need that one feels every day of one's
life even though one does not
acknowledge it to be related to
something bigger than oneself it comes
out of our Brokenness the need to be
related to something bigger than our
puny little egos which convince us that
who we are is our stuff and our
accumulations and our achievements and
our reputation it's like we know that we
need more than our stuff and our
approval and our Awards and our
reputations to be connected and and
that's a sense of Brokenness broken from
Spirit broken from the return trip da is
the way of return it's
returning to the place from which we
started and know it for the first time
and she says but the the need that one
feels every day of one's life even
though one does not acknowledge it to be
related to something bigger than oneself
something more alive than oneself
something older and something not yet
born that will endure through time that
was Lillian Smith writing in the
introduction to the journey that out of
this need to overcome this Brokenness
comes uh comes the afternoon of our life
comes this time when when we say my
connection to God to source to Da to
Universal Mind to to Spirit to that from
which I originated from which I can
never be disconnected which is who and
what I am my own Divinity it's never too
late to teach that and it's never too
early to teach that you can do it with
your babies this is why I've written
I've got two little children's books two
wonderful children's books one's called
incredible you and the other one just
came out it's called Unstoppable me so
now we enter this this thing this change
this something takes us takes over for
us and this thing called a Quantum shift
or a Quantum change in our hearts uh
takes over and once it does there's no
going back so now well let me describe
first the uh the quantum shift the
quantum change in a book called Quantum
change they suggest that when these
things come into your life and and and
the shift is on that um the experiences
are so dramatic that they often are
accompanied by uh voices that we hear
and an energy that we experience in our
life that no one else knows here's um a
friend of mine his name is Bill W Bill
Wilson yeah for those of you who don't
know why they're clapping he was the
founder of Alcoholics Anonymous and
before Bill W when you had alcoholic
psychosis you just died it was incurable
and he found something where he brought
spirit and God and helped people to
return to the source of well-being from
which they originated and to live from
there which requires nothing external to
ourselves in the way of substances and
he said these words about this it's
called the mystical type of quantum
change he said my depression deepened
unbearably and finally it seemed to me
as though I were at the bottom of the
pit I still gagged badly at the notion
of a power greater than
myself that's the ego at work but
finally just for a moment the last
vesage of my proud obstinacy was crushed
all at once I found myself crying out if
there is a God let him show himself I am
ready to do anything anything and
suddenly the room lit up with a great
white light I was caught up into an
ecstasy which there are no words to
describe it seemed to me in the Mind's
Eye that I was on a mountain and that a
wind not of air but of spirit was
blowing and then it burst upon me that I
was a free man a wind of spirit it
happened for me when I left drinking 19
years ago it was 407 a.m. and I awoke
and I had been thinking about this whole
thing because I wasn't and I never have
been and I am not now an alcoholic I
drank every day I drank two or three
beers in the evening I was never drunk I
just walked away from it when I had
enough none of the symptoms of alcohol
I've had other many other labels that
I've placed on myself but that happens
not to be one of them I had a teacher in
India who told me if you want to reach
the level of Consciousness that you were
destined to reach and that is your
vision you have to leave alcohol behind
and I said I have no trouble with that I
just want to have a couple of beers each
day after I run and he said no you will
do it and when you do it it will be easy
and I awoke at 4:07 a.m. and I couldn't
remember a day in the previous 15 years
that I hadn't had at least two or three
beers and um the room changed there was
like almost like a a spray in in the
room it was I I can still smell it it
was it was a smell of almost like like
roses in the room and I can remember
everything that was on the dresser I can
remember the clothes that were hanging
in the closet I can remember the color
of the sheets exactly what I was wearing
at that moment everything about that
room I can still remember and in the
quantum change they said there are four
qualities or characteristics that come
to you when you experience one of these
shifts and you can call upon it one is
that they are always a surprise two is
that they are extremely Vivid very Vivid
almost as if you're looking through
different lenses and the colors get
sharper and brighter they are also
always benevolent that is they are
always you feel like you're in the
presence of something that is just
overwhelmingly loving I getting it now
it's like a Kundalini it's like a warm
shower just running up and down your
spine it feels like pure love it's why I
always enter the room from the back you
can feel the love you can feel feel that
and in one of those moments you're in a
benevolent experience and fourth is that
it's always enduring so it's surprising
it's Vivid it's benevolent and it
endures and it's 19 years later and it
happened yesterday there was never even
a thought of having alcohol again and it
wasn't like I stayed away from it I
worried about it I didn't go to places
it was just out of my life it was one of
those Quantum shifts now you don't have
to have a moment like that it doesn't
have to be where you have this
magnificent kind of hearing a voice many
people do hear voices it can be anything
at all that is so profound for you that
you know that you have been visited by a
force that you have always been
connected to but you're now listening to
for the first time and when it happens
for women before one of these
experiences their number one through
five priorities in their life when asked
to list the values that were most
significant to them out of 60 choices
they picked one taking care of my family
two being independent three having a
career four fitting in and five being
attractive those were the qualities and
characteristics the values that women
picked after one of these Quantum
experiences the number one priority was
their personal growth the second was
their self-esteem feeling good about
myself third was spirituality and
staying connected to God fourth was a
sense of Happiness my own personal
happiness and five was living in a
spirit of generosity and giving that was
the shift that took place that's a major
shift from taking care of my family to
my own personal self-esteem and feeling
good about myself to now for men before
and after the number one through five
qualities or characteristics values out
of the top 60 listed was for men it was
this is before one of these Quantum
shifts was wealth the accumulation of
wealth which is what we're trained in
isn't it secondly was a sense of
adventure third was feeling a sense of
achievement in my life fourth was my own
personal uh sense of pleasure and fifth
was to be respected by others after one
of these experiences a visitation from
da a connection a reconnection to Source
the number one quality and
characteristic of a man and this
happened for me for sure was
spirituality the second was personal
peace the third was family taken care of
and loving family the fourth was living
God's will or living at God realization
and the fifth was honesty look at the
shifts look at the look at what happens
what takes place when these kinds of
shifts come into our lives when we go
from the morning of our life when our
primary purpose in life is to live out
this ego
and the ego is this idea that we have of
who we are that says who I am is what
other people think of me and who I am is
what I accumulate and who I am is what I
achieve and that's what I that's the
whole focus of my life and the problem
with that as a as a perspective of a way
of living is that if you are what you
have then what you begin to
realize is that when you don't have then
you aren't and if you are are what you
do and you no longer can do whatever
that can do is then you aren't and if
you are what other people think of you
and what other people think of you
changes which it always does then who
you are has no substance no value it's
located in something outside of yourself
so it's ephemeral and it's um it's
devastating if you want to get to the
end of your life and not be able to not
have to say what Ivan illich Leo
tolstoy's famous character in The Death
of Ivan illich said as he was lying on
his deathbed looking up at his wife whom
he despised because he felt that she was
responsible for all of the things that
he had to do that he was unhappy with
and he looked into her eyes as he was
dying and said what if my whole life has
been wrong can you imagine any I mean
just even saying that you know just is
is hurts inside what if you had to go to
the end of your life and say what if
what if my whole life has been wrong and
I think about these Quantum moments and
how they can come and when they can come
and there's a lady here in the room who
um has become one of the closest people
in the world to me someone I adore her
name is immaculate
Iliza and she was in Rwanda in 1994
sitting in a bathroom waiting to be
executed by machetes being hunted by hus
where they killed 1 million people from
her tribal ancestry the the tootsies and
she had a moment in that
bathroom in which she was asking God how
can I love how can I love these people
who are trying to kill me and she was
being hunted every day from April the
7th until July the 4th or 5th of
1994 and they spared no one
and she was told in a voice she was told
you must love them you must be able to
send them love and she said when she
finally got that a cross was placed
across the room an invisible cross that
only she could see and she knew she
didn't hope she didn't think anymore
that it might or might not she had an
absolute knowing that no one could
penetrate that cross 400 people with
machetes searched that house nine times
with within 90 days it's a two-bedroom
Bungalow house by American Standards and
they never found her she was just hidden
with seven other women behind a valet
Clos valet and they never looked there
and they looked everywhere under the
beds they even looked in suitcases for
babies cuz they would hack the babies to
death and she wrote a book which I wrote
the forward to and when I met her I knew
I was in the presence of an angel It's
called left to tell if you don't take
anything else home from this conference
read it's about the power of faith and
what it can do to uh transform one's
life and um when I read her manuscript I
knew I had to be involved in the
publication there's some
accurate
Immaculate stand up say hello to these
people Immaculate
Iliza I love
you she's the saint who walks Among Us
in many ways other ways I have a little
problem but uh I traveled with her for a
year and a half and she's become like I
don't know a friend and and a colleague
and a daughter and a loving beautiful
partner in this whole vision of
transforming the world and um 60 Minutes
has just uh spent over a million dollars
on uh went back to Africa with her and
reunited the all of the women but one
who died of AIDS in the bathroom and are
telling her story it'll be out watching
for it within the next few weeks or
months it's all in the can and ready to
go and it's one of the great great shows
you'll be seeing it on on the Left To
Tell this Quantum shift when it happens
when there's a knowing within you and I
started out by talking about passion
that when you have that passion you are
in Balance that's what being in Balance
really means we have desires and these
desires when they are aligned with
spirit
when these desires are so aligned with
spirit that we know that this is our
passion this is God speaking to us this
is my desire and it's not about getting
for me it's about what I'm here to give
and do because giving is what God always
does asking nothing in return it's about
giving anonymously the great Persian
poet HAF said in all the history of
people in the whole history of time the
sun has never said to the Earth you owe
me and then he said just think what a
love like that can do it lights up the
whole
world it lights up the whole world and
of course in Miracles there's this
wonderful line of Jesus saying if you
want to be like me I will help you if
you want to be like me I will help you
knowing that we are alike if you want to
be different than me I will wait until
you change your mind and you will change
your mind you may have to get back to
that place and the only way getting back
to it may be to die but you
will you will change your mind now I had
a story a letter come to me that is so
illustrative of all that I have been
speaking here about this idea of quantum
shifts the interconnectedness of all
things and the awareness that we can get
into the afternoon of our life live out
what our highest values are and access
whatever it is that we need by having
passion about the
outcome never being in doubt just having
that passion and the question is can you
do it question is can you do can you
have the knowing I've gotten this sort
of reputation for being able to heal uh
animals I can't do it with people but
animals for some reason I have a very
deep connection to say Francis and
people when they brought animals to me
with like these uh huge tumors cancerous
tumors and so on or cat with leukemia
and they presented these cats for some
reason just by and when they say can you
do this I say uh absolutely well don't
you have any no I don't have any doubt
at all it's an absolute knowing it's
sort of like when they ask saaba this
Divine soul in puta parte in India on
her 75th birthday are you God they ask
him in front of all the cameras with
millions of people surrounding the
village of puta parte he said uh yes I
am he said and so are you he said the
only difference between you and me is
that I know it and you doubt it can you
get to the non-d doubting place the
absolute knowing that this inner
beckoning this feeling that you have
inside about wanting your life to
improve about wanting to make a
difference about wanting to be closer to
God about wanting to promote peace in
the world about whatever it is that you
have a knowing about do you are you able
to banish the doubt in such a way that
you're willing to invite whatever it is
that's going to show up and know that
it's all for your best even if it shows
up as an obstacle so here's the letter
that I received I love this letter It
Was Written March the 20th 2006 I was
having the roughest time of my life
three years of pain Darkness loss and
self-pity not knowing how to hope as
usual I got up early to feed my horses
opened the glass door and at my feet was
a tiny baby bird covered in down I
looked her over and she was fine I
searched my entire acre rooftop and all
trying to find her nest to put her back
in safe and sound but all to no avail no
Nest anywhere to be seen where did she
come from and what am I going to feed
her I tried feeding her small bits of
fruit nope then dug up worms nope then
remembered having some seed in my garage
several different colors and sizes of
seeds and she would eat only the red
ones but she was eating and I was happy
she was growing fast and became friends
with my dog as they played together in
the yard my dog slapping her in the face
and slapping my dog back with her wings
she loved riding my horse and would
perch up on top of my thoroughbreds ass
and take a ride as she grew I would help
her to strengthen her wings so she could
fly and she would fly just a few feet at
a time but she always wanted to be with
us me my dog and my horses every morning
around time to feed the horses she would
be at my kitchen window knocking let me
in or feed me or something once in a
while she would come in and spend the
night with us but mostly she just wanted
her meal when she finally did learn to
fly I would take my dog for a walk and
I'd see her on my rooftop watching us
walk away that's too far for me to fly
I'm scared she seemed to be saying and
one morning during our walk I could see
her watching us I called to her come on
lover d come on lover d you can make it
just try I could see her attempting to
take off but she would back off and try
again and again as we waited for her to
half a block away I'd call her again
come on lover d and lo and behold she
took off flapped her wings and flew
directly to my waiting hands a half a
block all by herself by this time she
was at my kitchen window every single
morning knocking knocking at my window
for her breakfast she would eat then
take off for the day not to be seen
until her evening meal but she always
came home during this entire time I was
the saddest I had ever been in my life I
was alone I was lonely and I was afraid
very little family and very few friends
my cousin from Buffalo called me one day
to see how I was doing and she asked me
to come to Buffalo to visit for a week I
agreed to come because I thought it
might do me some good my mother agreed
to take care of my house and my animals
mom I said as daughters say to their
mothers be sure that lover d comes home
to eat she will come to the window when
she's ready and she will knock as hard
as that is to believe mom laughed but
she agreed to care for lover do nearly
every day I would call Mom and ask if
lover d came home and Mom would laugh
and say yes she came to the window she
knocked and I fed her and she'd say yes
well that's a big load off my mind she
said I brought a couple of books with me
to Buffalo to read on the plane
self-help books of course she said I
needed help with my sadness and my
loneliness and my purpose in this world
and I looked everywhere all the while
asking am I serving any purpose on this
planet am I worthy of my blessings am I
supposed to spend the rest of my days
alone on my way back on the plane I
pulled out my book I hadn't started it
yet but I started reading with chapter 1
a book by Wayne Dyer who I believe is a
highly evolved spiritual
Master well she says I got kind of bored
with the first
chapter so much for the highly evolved
spiritual master and I started thumbing
through the pages reading paragraphs
here and there and just as the plane was
ready to land I felt an overwhelming
feeling of sadness I'm going home but to
what the chores the walls the silence
who would who will be happy to see me
when I get home nobody trying to hide
the tears flowing down my face from my
neighbor on the plane I flipped to the
very last page of that book there the
author says I want to end this book with
one of my favorite poems entitled
Guardian Angels it deserves to be read
slowly and lovingly well I cannot
express the warmth in my chest the
moment I read the very first line of
that poem so this was written 20 years
before that it's called your see it when
you believe it and this was my turning
point when I wrote this book it was the
first book that I wrote that was not
about psychology it was about
spirituality major shift in my life had
to talk the publisher into it said it
wouldn't work and all of that so here's
how I ended this book a sensitive
Norwegian poet Ralph Jacobson wrote a
beautiful poem entitled Guardian Angel
it deserves to be read slowly and
lovingly I am the bird that knocks at
your window in the morning and your
compan compion whom you cannot know the
blossoms that light up for the blind I
am the glacier's crest above the forest
the dazzling one and the brass voices
from the cathedral Towers the thought
that suddenly comes over you at midday
and fills you with a singular
happiness I am the one you have loved
long ago I walked alongside You by day
and look intently at you and put my
mouth on your heart but you don't know
it I am your third arm and your second
Shadow the white great one whom you
don't have the heart for and who can
never ever forget you I am the bird that
knocks at your window in the morning
now this book the ending of that book I
don't have the time but it could take me
an hour to tell you the struggle I had
about whether to include that poem in
that book or not I put it in I took it
out I called my editor in New York I
said I don't really think it's an
appropriate ending to this she said then
take it out' I said okay take it out 24
hours before it was to be published I
put it back in 12 hours before I took it
out and the last hour before I had
Galley deadlines I called up and said
put the damn thing in I can't get it out
of my mind what's the connection between
am I doing it or was I being done and
was um Ralph Jacobson in Norway writing
this poem knowing about this woman out
in uh in Nevada who was desperate and
lonely listen to the conclusion of her
letter needless to say I was overwhelmed
by the message I had just received
coincidence I think not that was one of
the first times I had a genuine smile on
my face in three years it was the start
of my healing and a blessing in disguise
shortly thereafter I never saw lover d
again she didn't come home that morning
or any
morning thereafter so
coincidences all of that kind of thing
the interconnectedness between all of
things the awareness that when you begin
to open your eyes and shift what would
motivate her to pick up that book 20
years after it was published to carry it
on a plane and to have me and you know
that poem wasn't even a poem that I
discovered it was given to me by my very
first doctoral student Pat Murphy at St
John's University in New York he said
this is so beautiful I think you should
put it in your book back and forth and
you're doing it and you're back and
you're forth and you're think that
you've got it all handled so the only
thing I didn't mention was this
wonderful what I called my bathroom book
I didn't write it but it's myself deepo
Chopra Maryanne Williamson who is here
Mother Teresa the Dal Lama Louise Hay
ramas Bernie seagull Scotty peek Joan
Boris ankle I want you to put this in
your bathroom because it replaces the
energy that is leaving with the highest
energy of the
P there you are the experience of God
and so we come to the end at least the
end of my presentation here we shall not
cease our exploration and when we finish
exploring we shall return to the place
from which we came and know it for the
first time but you don't have to die to
go there you can access a Quantum moment
you can make the shift into the
afternoon of your life and live it by
those rules rather than anybody else's
that were handed to you so you no longer
have to live that lie I close with one
of my all-time favorite poems from Mary
Oliver who I think is America's great
contemporary poet it's called wild geese
you do not have to be good you do not
have to walk on your knees for a 100
miles through the desert repenting you
only have to let the soft animal of your
body love what it loves tell me about
despair yours and I'll tell you mine
meanwhile the world goes on meanwhile
the sun and the clear Pebbles of the
rain are moving across the Landscapes
over the Prairies and the Deep trees the
mountains and the rivers meanwhile the
wild geese high in the clean blue Air
are heading home again whoever you are
no matter how
lonely the world offers itself to your
imagination calls to you like the wild
geese harsh and exciting over and over
announcing you your place in the great
family of things in every moment ladies
and gentlemen every moment of your life
you have that great choice offered to us
from the course you can either be a host
to God the da or a hostage to Your Ego
it's your call the wild geese are
calling you home thank you and God bless
you
Namaste also to make sure your actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free free
there's a link in the description below
go click on it and start building the
momentum in your life and your business
I'll see you there to watch another
amazing Wayne Dyer video check it out
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there I have a right to be happy I
have a right to be unhappy you'll hear
people say it all the time I have a
right to be miserable and they go around
defending their right to be miserable
and when you defend your right to be
miserable you attract exactly what
you're defending into your life